Hagamos algunos problemas relacionados con
expresiones variables.
El primero dice, escribe las siguientes en una forma más condensada eliminando el signo de multiplicación,
eliminando un signo de multiplicación.
Tenemos para empezar 2 por "11x", si tenemos
"11x" y lo vamos a multiplicar por 2,
entonces vamos a tener "22x".
Una manera de ver esto es, si tenemos 2 por "11x",
esto es igual a 2 por 11 que multiplica
a "x" y esto es igual a "22x",
si teníamos "11x" y vamos a tener el doble de eso, vamos a terminar con "22x", siguiente.
1.35 por "y", en este caso vamos a hacer una
simplificación directa para reescribirlo...
déjame hacerlo con otro color...
1.35 por "y", ahí tenemos un pequeño punto,
el cual podemos eliminar directamente.
En álgebra, cuando tenemos un número que
antecede a una variable, quiere decir que
estamos multiplicando ese número por la variable.
Así es que esto lo podemos escribir como
"1.35y", la hemos condensado
al eliminar el signo de multiplicación.
Seguimos con 3 por 1/4,
es una multiplicación de fracciones directa.
Entonces la respuesta del 3, a ver, veamos,
aquí tenemos el 1, aquí tenemos el 2, aquí
tenemos el 3, que es 3 por 1/4,
escribimos el denominador del 3 que es 1 y hacemos la multiplicación, 3 por 1 es igual a 3,
1 por 4 es igual a 4, esto es 3/4,
para el número 3 tenemos 3/4.
Finalmente, un cuarto por "z".
Podemos hacer exactamente lo mismo que hicimos
en el número 2, es un problema similar a
"1.35y" que es lo mismo que 1.35 por "y",
así es que esto de acá abajo, lo podemos
escribir como "1/4z"
ó también podemos hacer ese producto, esto sería, 1 entre 4 por "z" entre 1, hacemos el producto,
1 por "z" es igual a "z", 4 por 1 es igual a 4, así que
esto es igual a "z" sobre 4,
así que todos estos son equivalentes.
Veamos ahora que quieren que hagamos.
Evalúa las siguientes expresiones para "a" igual a -3...
para "a" igual a -3, "b" igual a 2...
"b" igual a 2, "c" igual a 5...
"c" igual a 5 y "d"...
y "d" igual a -4 ó 4 negativo podríamos decir.
En este caso tan solo tenemos que sustituir,
cada que nos encontremos con una "a", sustituimos -3,
cada que nos encontremos con una "b", sustituimos 2,
cuando encontremos una "c", sustituimos 5,
y cuando encontremos una "d", sustituimos -4.
Por limitaciones de tiempo no voy a hacer todos,
haré unos cuantos.
Hagamos entonces el 5, pregunta 5.
Nos dan 2 por "a" más 3 por "b".
Bien, esto equivale a 2 por "a" que vale -3,
2 por -3 más 3 por el valor de "b", el valor
de "b" nos están dando que es 2,
esto es entonces 3 por 2,
¿y esto a qué es igual?
2 por -3... 2 por -3 es igual a -6, déjame usar otro color,
2 por -3 es igual a -6 más 3 por 2,
3 por 2 que es igual a 6 y esto es igual a 0.
Nota el orden que usamos en las operaciones, hicimos primero los productos "2a" y "3b" y luego la suma.
Tenemos que recordar siempre que la multiplicación y la división tienen precedencia sobre la suma y la resta.
Hagamos la pregunta 6... hagamos la pregunta 6,
la voy a hacer por acá...
6 es "4c" más "d", 4 por el valor de "c"
que es 5, 4 por 5 más el valor de "d",
"d" nos están dando que vale -4... -4...
4 por 5 es igual a 20 y más -4 es simplemente
-4, 20 menos 4 es igual a 16.
Hagamos ahora uno no tan fácil, hagámoslo acá abajo.
Esta pregunta 10 es la que se ve un poco más
complicada, aquí la tenemos, pregunta 10.
Pregunta 10, nos dan una fracción, en el
numerador tenemos "a" menos "4b",
casi no se ve, está muy pequeño pero bueno, tenemos
"a" que es igual a -3 menos 4 por el valor de "b",
"b" que vale 2, así que esto es -4 por 2.
Hemos sustituido aquí el valor de "a" y aquí
el valor de "b".
¿Y cómo sé que son esos valores?
Nos los están dando acá arriba.
Y todo eso sobre...
todo eso sobre "3c" más "2d", sustituyendo
los valores 3 por "c", el valor de "c" que
tenemos es 5, 3 por 5 más 2 por "d",
más 2 por -4 que es el valor de "d" que nos están
dando, más 2 por -4.
Calculemos el valor de esta expresión, los
productos tienen precedencia sobre la suma y la resta.
Haciendo entonces las operaciones, ¿qué nos da?
En el numerador tenemos -3 menos 4 por 2,
-3 menos 8 dividido entre 3 por 5, que es
15, más 2 por -4, 2 por -4 = -8,
15 más -8, 15 menos 8...
Y así, el numerador resulta, -3 menos 8 = -11
y el denominador 15 menos 8 = 7.
Esto es -11 sobre 7 ó -11/7.
Y aquí la tenemos, esta es la respuesta de
la pregunta 10.
Hagamos ahora unos de estos,
aparecen algunos exponentes.
Haré uno de los difíciles.
Hagamos este, hagamos esta pregunta 18.
Pregunta 18, en esta pregunta nos dan,
"2x" cuadrada menos "3x" cuadrada más "5x" menos 4.
Bueno, no estuvo tan difícil, tan solo depende de "x", hagámoslo por acá arriba.
Tenemos "2x" cuadrada menos "3x" cuadrada más "5x" menos 4 y nos dan que "x" es igual a -1.
Algo que podemos hacer es simplificar esto
antes de sustituir el valor de "x" igual a -1.
Así es que, ¿cuánto es 2 de algo menos 3 de algo?
Aquí tenemos "2x" cuadrada menos "3x" cuadrada,
así es que 2 de algo menos 3 de algo,
nos va a dar -1 de ese algo,
así es que esto de aquí es "-1x"
cuadrada más "5x" menos 4.
Sustituyendo el valor de "x" igual a -1 que
nos dan, aquí tenemos -1 por -1
elevado al cuadrado más 5 por -1 menos 4.
¿y esto a qué es igual?
-1 elevado al cuadrado es 1 positivo, esto
es 1 positivo por -1 esto es igual a -1,
más 5 por -1 es -5, así es que hay que
restarle menos 5 y -4.
¿y esto cuánto es?
-1 menos 5 = -6, menos 4 = -10, esto es igual a -10.
Y ahora, haré estos dos últimos problemas,
que son una muestra del tipo de problemas que nos encontramos en esta sección de expresiones variables.
El costo semanal "C" de fabricar "x" controles remotos,
así es que "C" es costo y "x" son controles remotos,
está dado por la fórmula,
el costo es igual a 2000 más 3 por el número
de controles remotos,
donde el costo está dado en dólares. Inciso a.
¿Cuál es el costo de producir 1000 controles remotos?
1000 controles remotos...
el número de controles remotos es "x", así es que aplicando la fórmula, voy a escribirlo por acá.
El Costo es igual a 2000... el costo es igual a 2000 más 3 por el número de controles remotos
que en este caso es "x" que es el
número de controles remotos que es 1000.
Y esto va a ser igual entonces a 2000 más
3 por 1000, es 3000,
al final de cuentas el costo es 5000 dólares, así que la respuesta al inciso a es, 5000 dólares.
Ahora inciso b.
¿Cuál es el costo de producir 2000 controles remotos?
Bueno, la fórmula es la misma, Costo es igual
a 2000, 2000 más 3 por "x" que es el número
de controles remotos, que en este caso es
2000, 2000 controles remotos.
Y esto es igual a 2000 más 3 por 2000, es
6000, dándonos un total,
un costo total de 8000 dólares.
Muy bien, ahora hagamos el problema 22
El volumen de una caja sin tapa está dado
por la fórmula,
"V" es igual a "4x" por 10 menos "x" al cuadrado,
donde "x" es una longitud en pulgadas
y "V" es el volumen en pulgadas cúbicas.
¿Cuál es el volumen cuando "x" es igual a 2?...
Inciso a.
¿Cuál es el volumen cuando "x" es igual a 2?
Bueno, donde tengamos "x" sustituimos el valor de 2.
El volumen es entonces 4 por 2,
que multiplica a 10 menos 2,
10 menos 2 elevado al cuadrado.
Esto es igual a 4 por 2 es igual a 8...
4 por 2 es igual a 8 y 10 menos 2 es igual
a 8, elevado al cuadrado.
Y esto es lo mismo que 8 al cubo, esto es
igual a 8 por 8 al cuadrado que es 64.
¿y esto cuánto nos va a dar?
Esto es igual a 64 por 8, 8 por 4 =32 llevamos 3,
8 por 6... 8 por 6 = 48 y 3 es 51... 51... 512, el volumen de este inciso a es 512 pulgadas cúbicas.
Ahora, ¿cuál es el volumen cuando "x" es igual a 3?
Lo voy a hacer aquí en rosa.
Inciso "b", cuando "x" es igual a 3, el volumen
es, 4 por 3, "x" es igual a 3 ahora...
por 10 menos 3 al cuadrado.
4 por 3 es igual a 12 por 10 menos 3 que es 7 al cuadrado. Esto es igual a 12 por 49.
Vamos a hacer el producto aquí abajo, esto
es 49 por 12, es igual, 2 por 9 = 18 llevamos 1,
2 por 4 = 8 y 1 = 9, ponemos aquí un 0,
1 por 9 es igual a 9, 1 por 4 es 4,
hacemos la suma y tenemos que es 8, 9 y 9 = 18 llevamos 1, 1 y 4 son 5...
el volumen es 588.